- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large brain. Long the
master of fire, tools, and language but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here; an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Pascal] Welcome to this 24th CARTA
symposium. My name is Pascal Gagneux. I'm
the Associate Director of CARTA. Among the
oldest questions that humans have asked
figure questions such as, "Who are we?"
"What are we doing here?" "Where did we
come from?" "How did we get here?" and
"Where are we going?" Anthropogeny is the
scientific quest to address two of these
questions, "Where did we come from?" and
"How did we get here?" that we at CARTA
believe are addressable with scientific
data from a great number of disciplines.
Anthropogeny, it turns out, is a very old
term that has vanished and we have
resuscitated it. The Center for Academic
Research and Training in Anthropogeny is
an enterprise between UCSD and Salk, and
it spans the general campus and health
sciences as well as Salk. It is
co-directed by Ajit Varki, Fred Gage, and
Margaret Schoeninger. Our MSO is Linda
Nelson. Our Community Director...
Relations Director is Ingrid
Benirschke-Perkins. Kate Kaya is in charge
of all our computer and computer
analysis, Jesse Robie, our Program
Coordinator, and Stefi Petit, our
Administrative Assistant. As I mentioned,
trying to answer these two age-old
questions will only be possible if we draw
on the humanities, on biological sciences,
engineering and computing sciences, as
well as physical and chemical sciences,
biomedical sciences, social sciences. Many
of the people involved in these venues of
studying humans are not used to talking to
each other, at least not on a daily basis.
So we really try to encourage regular
interactions between scientists from very
different fields. Our mission statement is
the following: "Use all rational and
ethical approaches to seek all verifiable
facts from all relevant disciplines to
explore and explain the origins of the
human phenomenon, doing so while
minimizing complex organizational
structures and hierarchies and avoiding
unnecessary paperwork and bureaucracy."
Unfortunately, there is also electronic
bureaucracy these days, and we also try to
do so, "In the process, raise awareness
and understanding of the study of human
origins within the academic community and
the public at large," which is why these
symposia are free and open to the public.
I would like to point out that this is
only possible due to many people who
support us, first and foremost the G.
Harold and Leila Y. Mathers Charitable
Foundation of New York and Howard Chester
the Executive Director. I would like
to take a moment to remind you that we've
lost a very, very valuable friend and
supporter who always supported our
initiatives and really contributed greatly
to the spirit of these symposia, but much
more so of everything CARTA does, and this
Jim Handelman, who we lost earlier
this year. He has come to many of the
symposia. He has had an important role in
shaping how we do the symposia. He was a
very strong force behind the idea of
involving a small group of highly
motivated grad students to include them in
the symposia, and we will miss him dearly.
We have established a memorial symposium
fund in his honor. We need to thank, and
if you'd like to read more about Jim
Handelman, our latest Tracks, CARTA
Tracks which is a newsletter, you can find
as a PDF online or pick up copies outside,
has a very nice, conscise, two-page story
that will convince you very rapidly how
crucial Jim was in the development of
CARTA from a very long time ago when it
was a small group of scientists on the
mesa here interested in explaining
human origins. The UC is the project for
explaining human origins to CARTA. That
started eight years ago. We need to thank
many other supporters, including Liz
Lancaster and Eli Shefter, that make
possible the closed captioning on the
recordings, and of course Annette
Merle-Smith for the support that she
provides for the graduate specialization
in anthropogeny at UC San Diego. And we
have a growing list of individual
supporters who make these events possible.
Thank you to all of them. And of course,
none of this would be possible without a
big team, a crew of people here at
UC-TV, Rich Wargo, Matt Alioto, Marci
Bretts, Jacob Parker, as well as, of
course, the Salk Media Services, Kent
Schnoeker and Krys Schempp. So
without further ado...one last thing. Some
of you might not be aficionados of genomic
or genetic sciences. If you hear acronyms
that sound strange, you might want to pick
up this two-page glossary that the
specialization students tried to generate
to help you navigate the many acronyms
that you usually hear in genetics and
genomics talks. So with that, I welcome
you all and I'll pass the podium to Ed
Green who will chair the first half of the
symposium.
♪ [music] ♪